I'm not saying this is definitely a plot
for a British Ocean's-11 style
heist caper,
but if there are any screenwriters
out there watching this:
I feel like this one might be for you.
British coins have the year that they
were manufactured right on them.
So if you're a coin collector,
and your dream is the full set,
it's not just a case of finding
one of each design:
you also want each value
from each year.
But in 1933, Britain didn't
need any more pennies.
There were plenty in circulation,
so the Royal Mint,
who make - or "mint" - coins,
decided they wouldn't make
any one-pence coins that year.
That's not unusual,
it had happened before.
Trouble is, King George V needed some.
It was tradition for the King to bury
a full set of new coins from that year
in the foundations of new and important
buildings as they were constructed,
and you couldn't use old coins for that.
So the Royal Mint did make
some 1933 pennies.
No-one actually kept the records
of how many there were,
but it was probably...
seven.
Which means that while the face value
of those seven coins is a penny,
they're so rare that the price
at auction these days
is easily more than £100,000.
And over at a London coin dealership,
I got to see one of them.
- This is from a private collection,
one that's been loaned to us very kindly.
It's great because it's such an iconic coin,
we get a lot of visitors coming to see it.
Usually these coins disappear into safes
and they're never seen again.
The last sold in 2016 for a hammer price
of around £140,000.
It's the first time one's been sold
for many, many years
and one would imagine, if it was
to come on the market again,
it would sell for even higher.
- So there are probably seven 1933 pennies.
Three are in private collections
I got to film one of those.
Two are in museums.
And the others...
...well, that's the possible heist movie.
Because remember, the king
buried some of the coins.
One of them was buried under this church
in Middleton, West Yorkshire.
I say "was" because in 1970,
it was stolen.
Whereabouts still unknown,
although presumably
if someone in Yorkshire finds a 1933 penny
in their grandparents' coin collection,
there'll be a bit of suspicion.
And after this theft...
...the local bishop ordered that
the coins under this church
should be dug up and sold
in order to prevent them
falling into the hands of thieves.
That's one of the pennies that's
in private hands legally now.
Which means there is one building
and one buried coin left.
The last 1933 penny is buried somewhere
under the foundations of Senate House,
at the University of London.
Or at least, everyone thinks it is.
No-one's checked since 1933,
you'd have to dig it up.
And I doubt anyone actually knows
exactly where it's buried,
unless they've done a huge amount of research
and found some original blueprints.
Which, to be clear, I haven't.
And besides, according to the university,
the whole package is buried very deep,
not exactly where you'd expect,
which does sound like
what someone would write
if they were trying to discourage
amateur treasure-hunting thieves.
But Senate House is right here,
in the middle of London.
There is some construction around here today,
a few people in high-viz jackets
with power tools.
And while it's not exactly
cracking the vault of a Las Vegas casino...
well, I don't have a plan for you.
And I don't recommend anyone try it for real.
But it is a heist movie waiting to happen.
Seriously, don't try it. This isn't the movies.
It's... it's just a coin.
I don't have any plans to...
How do I make this sound not sarcastic?